Let's get the same issue that counted here sir.
Hair transplant too.
So he's got a scar back there.
It's getting so like probably didn't tell the world as fucking Rad.
He's talked about it before.
No,
he has.
I know.
I would never say it if you didn't know.
I'll tell you that.
You know that it's the best fucking here piece is a pivot.
That shit I had no idea.
Do you know he used to play George Costanza on Seinfeld because he had the same
fucking birds nest thing?
Well,
he had a bunch of surgeries I think.
Oh No.
That thing is dead meat up there.
Fucking thing is sewn into a skull.
I had no idea.
How dare you.
This is live.
Oh,
why people are listening.
I'm just saying he has fucking,
it's got great.
Good.
Sam's good,
good fake here.
Yes.
There's no problems.
No issues.
I'll probably do the same shit.
You know it's not the eighties though,
because in the eighties man,
if you had long hair and you were losing your hair,
it was basically a death sentence.
Like last year I had knew I had a senior.
No,
I can have a shaved head.
Back then [inaudible] was the only guy we allowed him to shave his head because
he could sing so great.
We just said,
okay,
well he was also allowed dressing really weird.
You know what,
this fucking biker leather,
she'll run like he dressed like a people in the gay community dress came out
with the leather and the motorcycles and all that shit and I'll show the cords.
All the kids thought that was heavy metal.
So I wore all that shit and I always thought in the back of my head I thought it
was weird that gay people were the same shit and no dudes do.
It must be a coincidence.
We've talked about that on the podcast before that Rob Halford con to whole
group of people and addressing gay.
How bout how bout um,
Freddy mercury was telling everybody he was super gay,
was not trying to hide it from anybody,
but I thought,
oh,
he's just a rock star.
His style is dope.
The band's name was queen,
but no one thought he was gay who just got on Shorstein one thought he was
getting probably can to some people,
but the masses,
not the magic a while.
You know,
watch the movie,
like the documentary.
Yeah.
Everyone was like,
whoa.
We looked back and I'm like,
you fucking joking.
And everybody,
Elton John,
but forget all of them have a rock.
She's the craziest one.
Liberace.
They were like Liberace.
When are you going to find a nice woman and settled on that?
I keep looking.
I can't find them.
I don't know.
I think Freddie Mercury's a little bit,
was a little crazier than,
no,
Liberace broken.
The name of his band was queen.
That's true.
But he's a lot of star rock star.
Liberace played a piano and came out and no fucking gold royals Royce and had
fucking pigeons coming out of his asshole and we're like,
no,
you know our mall.
Did we talk about this with girls of why there's such a disproportionate amount
of gay singers?
No.
Why?
Because who's dude?
Who's running the music business?
A lot of gay dudes.
And who's going to raise.
Is that true?
I don't know anything about that.
It's true.
It's no big deal.
But I run the music business.
Did you know that?
I didn't know that.
I know.
Who's who's,
who's showing up?
Who's down in the south?
La Reid's goose down to suck Dick.
Oh,
is that what quicker than a gay singer?
Wait a minute.
So you think the reason why there's so many gay singers are,
they're the ones who stuck to the decks to make to the top.
Because there's guys who are possible.
Jerry,
hold on,
but let me offer you,
let me gay.
Let me offer you an alternative explanation.
Y'All are straight.
Here's the AUC.
Hold on.
Here's the alternative explanation.
Gay People,
uh,
feel maligned.
They feel like they're left out.
They are sad because of this.
They live hard lives.
They maintain all of this emotion inside of them and they want to express it
some way.
And so they figured out a way to sing and to entertain.
And God damn with Jamie that showed me a picture of [inaudible] behind the
Candelabra is the best movie ever.
That's what I think.
I think you know,
they're bullied and you know they're depressed and they're the people that are
the most like pushed out in society.
Those are the ones who become comedians.
It was the ones that become singers.
Those are the ones they become actors even cause they already shifting shit.
Something to get out and outlet.
Gay comedians think that many gang of them was a gang of it.
There's a couple.
No,
there's a gang of them.
There's a lot.
I know.
I know quite a few.
I'd say there's more gay actors that are seniors.
No seniors names named some few singers,
four or five.
But we got our dad to through a rob Halford still kicking Liberace died of
everything.
He had the full coffee help running around inside of them.
Just everything that Dick and plan all the dudes,
Joey Diaz has used to have a fucking bit and we played a little bit of it one
time on the podcast,
but it's not the best version of it.
Of beyond the Candelabra,
the fucking HBO movie with Matt Damon.
I loved that book.
And Michael Douglas Dude,
that show.
Do you remember Joey Diaz is bit,
yeah.
I taught in San Jose,
one of the best sets I've ever seen them do.
Uh,
in San Jose,
he had that whole bit down San Jose Improv show.
It was a,
he got rushed in monster,
please.
Still at monster.
But I mean,
that bit was just so funny.
That's such a funny.